Good morning.
Uh,
so this is kind of a transition week.
We've been talking about,
uh,
about more,
more basic,
more biological subjects.
And starting this week we're going to sort of mix,
uh,
physiology and biomedical engineering.
And,
um,
and that's going to start sort of this week.
And next what the,
the,
the topic for this week is a self communication,
how mechanisms that sells within a complex organism use to communicate with each
other at short distances or long distances.
And then we're going to talk about to physiological systems just briefly where a
cell communication sort of dominates the behavior of the,
of the organ and that's in the immune system and in the nervous system.
And this will lead us into a discussion of sort of bioengineering of the immune
system in particular.
And we're going to talk next week about,
about vaccines.
And um,
so this will be the first real example where we've talked about the physiology
of an organ system together with,
with,
uh,
engineering approaches to modulate that Oregon.
And that will continue throughout the,
throughout the semester.
So you'll notice that the chapters,
because of this go go out of sequence.
So we're reading chapters six this week and next week we'll read parts of
chapters 14 and 15.
And that's because the book has a different kind of organization.
It talks about the basics.
Then it talks about physiology and the second part,
and then it talks about biomedical engineering separately.
But we're going to in class treat the physiology and the biomedical engineering
together.
Okay.
Questions about that or that makes it,
makes some sense.
Okay.
So cell communication and immunology is what we're going to,
uh,
is the topic for this week.
And I don't need to say too much probably about why cells need to communicate
with each other.
Uh,
but,
uh,
this is a schematic virgin,
one way to draw,
to draw sort of a schematic diagram of the operation of the human body
where it shows separated organ systems and tries to show them in context the
respiratory system.
For example,
the renal system,
the digestive system.
These are examples,
three examples of organ systems that contact,
uh,
the external environment.
Right?
And we've talked about the interesting way in which the digestive system
contexts,
the external environment,
and depending on what you call external and internal environment,
this path that I'm tracing here deep within your digestive system is really
directly connected to the outside world,
right?
Through both ends.
But of course,
when molecules get absorbed through the intestinal track,
they become part of your internal environment.
And we talked about one of the main concepts in physiology being homeostasis.
That is how do you maintain a constant internal environment?
We need to have conditions internally that are relatively constant in terms of
temperature and Ph and chemical composition in order for us to thrive,
right?
In order for life to,
uh,
to proceed,
you need to maintain constant internal environment.
And that's achieved in fact,
that's the main goal of many of these organ systems,
right?
The main goal of the respiratory system is to bring fresh air in so you can
extract oxygen from it and blow used air out so that you can get rid of carbon
dioxide,
which is the end product of carbon metabolism inside our bodies.
All right?
And so the respiratory system plays an important role in,
in,
uh,
maintaining our internal environment at the proper level of oxygen,
right?
By bringing the right amount in and you regulate your breathing rate in order to
accomplish that.
And we'll talk about this in a,
in a couple of weeks,
the renal system has an equally important a function in that way in maintaining
your a water balance.
The amount of water that you need to have the optimal sort of concentrations of
things,
uh,
is determined by how much a urine your kidneys produce and how much they excrete
each day.
In addition,
the kidney,
uh,
controls the composition of your body of many important Dion's,
a sodium bicarbonate,
which is important to ph,
balance,
potassium,
and by a m by determining how many of those molecules to hold on to,
how many to keep in the body,
how many to release a determines the internal,
uh,
composition with regard to that ion.
Right.
And the digestive system,
of course,
is responsible for bringing in sort of fresh nutrients,
fresh substrates for cellular metabolism,
fresh quantities of amino acids and nucleotides.
And the things that,
uh,
we can't generate internally.
And so these are all involved with our,
uh,
our,
ability to maintain homeostasis by exchanging materials with the external
environment,
right?
There are some organ systems that are totally internal,
The circulatory system,
uh,
which we'll talk about in a couple of weeks.
The heart,
the blood vessels and the blood work together to form a totally internal
function,
right?
There's no point where the circulatory system,
uh,
crosses the boundary between being inside you and outside of you.
It's totally internal and its role is to move molecules around in the body so
that they're available to cells everywhere within your body,
regardless of how close they are to your skin.
And we'll talk about that.
And of course,
the nervous system,
the endocrine system,
which we'll start talking about a little bit today,
is this,
the system that's responsible for,
uh,
sending signals back and forth between tissues of your body.
The nervous system does the same thing in a different way,
right?
And so these two systems,
which are shown in the core of this diagram,
uh,
really are responsible for regulating and exchanging information between the
other organ systems,
right?
How did your lungs know what your heart is doing,
how your kid needs,
know what the status is of inside your blood.
For example,
they,
they know that because they receive signals from the endocrine system and the
nervous system.
These are primarily communication systems,
which act to allow your other organ systems to work in concert.
And we're going to talk about the mechanisms by which these,
uh,
work as well.
Now there's something very wrong about this diagram,
right?
In that it's showing these functions as sort of centralized in the core.
And of course,
that's not how your body is organized,
right?
You're,
it's not that all these layers are wrapped around the nervous system and the
endocrine system.
These systems are disbursed throughout your body and their disbursal is
important.
And so we'll talk about that as well.
So take a step way back and think about what's the basic mechanism by which
cells receive signals.
And it turns out that cells receive signals or,
or information from the rest of the body in a variety of ways.
Uh,
but there's one way in particular,
uh,
that's a very useful way for thinking about how cells receive most information.
And it's shown schematically on this diagram here.
And so on.
The,
on the side over here shows a cell membrane.
And so this is outside the cell above it.
And this is inside the cell,
uh,
below.
And this is,
this is the lipid bi layer that separates the outside of the cell from the
inside of the cell.
And I've already mentioned many times that the lipid bi layer,
the cell membrane isn't just a lipid bi layer,
that there are other molecules in the lipid biolayer and they're important for,
uh,
for uh,
cells getting information or getting molecules from outside.
We've talked about one class of molecules,
they're transporters that move molecules from inside to outside or outside to
end that wouldn't ordinarily be transported through a cell membrane.
And Glucose is a great example of that.
And we're going to come back to that a little bit later in the lecture.
If a,
if a cell membrane was indeed just a lip at by layer than glucose could never
enter the cell because it can't permeate through cell membranes.
Glucose has to get into cells.
That's the main source of uh,
of energy source.
That cells use metabolism of glucose and it does so because there are some
molecules in the surface of the membrane that allow glucose to move in and out.
Those are called glucose transporters.
There's another whole family of molecules that sit in the surface and they're
not responsible necessarily for moving molecules inside and out,
but they sit at the outside of the cell and they wait for signals and when they
receive the signal,
they make,
they change in a very specific way and the cell can recognize this change that's
occurred at the cell surface and that general class of molecules is called
receptors and it's shown here just as a,
as a block of material,
uh,
living in the cell membrane.
I'm going to talk about different classes of receptors in just a minute,
but for now,
just just picture it in the simple way as a molecule.
Usually a protein that's embedded in the cell membrane.
And many receptors have a part of their,
uh,
have a,
have a part of them that is extra cellular and they go across the membrane.
This is the transmembrane part of the receptor that's going across the membrane.
And then there's a part that's inside the cell sticking out it down into the
cell cytoplasm.
So this is called the extracellular region or domain.
This is the transmembrane region or domain.
And this is the cytoplasmic region or domain.
And because these molecules can span across the membrane from outside to inside
there in just the right position to take messages that they receive from outside
the cell and transmit them through the membrane into the cells internal
apparatus.
And that's what they do.
And the signal comes in the form of molecules,
which we're going to call throughout the lecture here.
Lie Gans and this terminology lie Ganden receptor.
Uh,
you've probably heard before.
It refers to usually receptors that are fixed in a cell on a cell membrane and
lie gans which are dispersed throughout the body and free to diffuse around.
And occasionally we'll find the cell and when they do find the cell they're
capable of interacting with the receptor forming some kind of chemical
interaction with the receptor.
Now usually this is a non covalent interaction.
There's not actually chemical covalent bonds that are formed,
but it's a non covalent interaction usually dominated by hydrogen bonding.
Um,
and we're going to talk about this kind non covalent interaction more when we
talk about the immune system.
Because one example of like end in receptors that's important in the immune
system are antigens foreign molecules and antibodies,
molecules that we produce.
But today,
let's think about it more generally as ligands and receptors,
the logins are bringing some message.
They,
they transmit the message by binding to the receptor and that when they bind,
they produce some change in the receptor molecule which is experienced inside
the cell.
And the way that the cell experience it is through some sort of biochemical
changes.
And those changes usually involve enzymes.
They often involve the generation of what are called Second Messenger Molecules,
which carry the signal further into the cell.
And they often involve networks of reactions,
not just one enzyme,
but a series of enzymes that serve to amplify each other so that the reaction
performed by one enzyme creates a product that stimulates another enzyme,
that creates a product that stimulates another enzyme.
And through this cascade of reactions,
you amplify and carry the signal forward.
Okay.
That's what's,
that's what's illustrated here with the end result being that there's some
change in the,
in the life of the cell.
Okay.
Now what would that change be?
Well,
it might be that this signal is a signal to divide.
It's time for you to reproduce.
And so the cellular response would be my Tosas,
right?
It could be that that signal is you need more glucose.
And so the cellular response is to create more glucose transporters to bring
more glucose into the cell.
It could be the responses.
There's something dangerous in the environment.
We've got to move away.
Right?
And so the response is for the cell to crawl in the opposite direction,
right?
So there's a diverse range of responses that might occur.
Uh,
but that response is initiated by this simple chemical process of,
uh,
of the ligand binding to a receptor.
Now the other thing to keep in mind is that for any cell,
there's not just one receptor on the cell,
all right?
There's not just one receptor on the cell.
There are,
uh,
there are thousands or hundreds of thousands of receptors and all of them could
potentially be receiving signals from a gander,
a chemical.
And so this pathway might not be the only one that's being activated inside the
cell at any given time.
It might be getting a signal from this receptor and it's signal from this
receptor and it's signal from this receptor.
And what the cell needs to be able to do is to integrate that information into a
response,
right?
Needs to be able to integrate that information into a response.
And that happens through these biochemical reactions.
Uh,
so I,
I hope that makes sense as background and I'm just going to basically illustrate
that basic concept with a few examples throughout the rest of the lecture.
Uh,
the other thing that's on this slide here is sort of a simple analogy,
uh,
that,
I've already described sort of,
if you think about a receptor Ligand,
a system as an input into the cell,
and if it was a,
if it was sound that was being received,
that might be a beating of a drum,
for example,
that sound gets con gets transduced.
And we're used to thinking about sound being transduced,
for example,
being converted by acoustic waves into electrical signals,
right?
That can be,
uh,
that can be recognized by your eye pods,
right?
Uh,
but it's,
same thing happens here.
There's a transduction one kind of a signal gets converted to another kind of a
signal in the case of a ligand receptor,
a chemical signal in the form of a concentration of lag,
and it gets converted into a biochemical signal.
And that signal is carried here,
for example,
by the concentration of second messengers,
the concentration of something else.
All right?
Often that signal gets amplified so it can be used.
Same thing happens inside cells and there's some output that's generated.
Uh,
what are one of the,
um,
this understanding of receptor lag and interactions has been really the
biological basis of much of the pharmaceutical industry.
Much of the work that pharmaceutical companies do in terms of searching for
drugs is searching for a new Lai gans
okay.
That activate receptors and create biological responses inside cells.
And there are two classes,
two broad classes of drug sort of type lie gans that are defined a agonist and
antagonist.
And An agonist is a substance that,
uh,
that mimics the action of a natural lag.
And so I'm,
and I show you a couple of examples of agonists here.
Now,
sometimes the agonist is the natural light end itself.
And that's an example of that is when you use insulin is a drug.
Insulin is a naturally occurring hormone.
It's a protein hormone that circulates in all of our bodies and it regulates
glucose metabolism.
When you don't produce enough insulin yourself as diabetics do not,
uh,
then you can use insulin as a drug.
And,
and what insulin is doing inside your body is,
is acting as a lie for insulin receptors,
which stimulate certain kinds of cellular responses.
I'll talk about that more in a minute.
Another example is in the nervous system,
patients that have Parkinson's disease have too little of a natural lie gand
called a dopamine.
And that can be,
it's supplied by an antagonist called El Dopa,
which is not exactly the same as dopamine.
It's slightly different.
It turns out when you give l Dopa to people,
it gets converted biochemically into natural dopamine,
which then,
which then serves as its own,
uh,
it's own agonist,
right?
But sometimes you can design drugs that act like,
uh,
that act like natural light guy without being the natural ligand.
And we've identified many drugs that stimulate insulin receptors,
for example,
but they're not exactly insulin.
And those can potentially be used as agonist type drugs.
And alternate is to design an antagonist.
And this would be an example of a substance that inhibits the,
the action of a natural gant.
And they can inhibit in a variety of ways.
Sometimes they inhibit by,
uh,
by just,
preventing the Lygen from interacting with its receptor.
They prevent the lie again,
from reaching its natural receptor.
And so that antagonizes or inhibits the function of the natural law.
Again,
sometimes they act by actually binding to the receptor and they bind sometimes
better than the natural again does,
but they don't create the right biological reaction.
So they bind to the receptor.
They,
they occupy the receptor.
So now the natural eigen can't enter it,
but they don't create the same sequence of biochemical events.
And so an example of a drug that works like that is the anti a cancer drug
Tamoxifen,
which binds to estrogen receptors and blocks,
estrogen signaling and many types of cancers,
particularly breast cancers,
many breast cancers,
but not all are sensitive to estrogen.
Estrogen is a natural signal for cells to grow.
It's a natural signal for cells to grow.
And if you design a drug that blocks estrogen interaction,
you stop growth.
Stopping growth in tumors can be a very beneficial thing,
right?
And there's a whole class of antagonistic,
uh,
drugs,
that have been designed to influence your cardiovascular system.
One,
one class of them is Beta blockers.
They bind to Beta adrenergic receptors,
which are receptors that,
that,
uh,
exchange information between your nervous system and,
um,
and the contractal system,
the beats of the beats your heart,
um,
and that causes the heartbeat.
And they can antagonize that reaction.
And as a result,
they affect,
they have blood rate and more importantly,
they can affect like blood pressure as well.
Uh,
the strength of your heartbeat and the pressure that your heart generates.
So these are just some examples
I mentioned earlier,
we thought about receptors as being these blocks and membranes,
but there,
there are different families of receptors.
And one useful thing about,
about separating receptors into types or families is that we found that many
different receptors work by the same basic underlying mechanism.
They might have different logins which stimulate them,
but once they're stimulated,
they work the same way.
And uh,
and understanding this has really has really,
uh,
led to lots of advances in,
in,
in biology.
We'll,
we'll talk about that as we come to it.
What I want to do in here is just,
it's just introduced some of the basic kinds of of receptors.
The one that's on the top here is called a ligand gated ion channel.
And an ion channel is a,
is a protein that sits in the surface of a cell and it can exist in a gated ion
channel,
can exist in one or two states,
a state where it's closed.
So imagine a channel with a lid on top of it.
When it's closed,
nothing can go through the channel.
When it's open,
then things can go through.
Now these are special channels and that they only allow certain molecules to
pass through.
And the ones that are most important in physiology are ones that only allow ions
to go through.
Sodium,
potassium chloride,
calcium by carbonate.
And we'll see just briefly in this course.
If you go on to study physiology,
you'll learn much more about how these,
these,
uh,
channels,
cause,
uh,
cause changes in,
um,
the electrical potential of cells,
which lead to events like conduction of nerve or a contraction of a muscle or a
beating of the heart.
We'll talk a little bit about that,
but not much for,
for these purposes.
Think about a channel.
It only allows sodium to go through.
For example,
it has a gate on it and that gate is in an open or closed state depending on
whether a lie again is present or not.
So if ally again comes and interacts with the receptor,
it opens up.
If the light gang goes away,
it closes.
And so in the presence of this lie Gann this molecule,
it's open,
it allows transport of the scion when the,
when the [inaudible] is gone,
it doesn't,
and that,
uh,
that changes the cell.
And here's some examples of it.
Many neurotransmitter's,
uh,
that carry signals between neurons in your brain,
work this way.
The cells that take an electrical signal,
which is coming down your nerve and converted into a muscle contraction work
this way,
right?
So neuro,
neuro nerve muscle junctions act,
uh,
based on Lygen gate gated ion channels.
Another family is called the g protein coupled receptor.
It's called the g protein coupled receptor because it's a receptor like the one
shown here that's coupled to a special molecule called a g protein.
When the Ligand is present,
it binds to the receptor outside the cell and it activates this g protein and
the g protein then goes on to create some other biochemical changes inside the
cell.
And uh,
we're not going to talk about this in any detail.
There's a little bit more detailed described in your book.
These are fascinating molecules that turned out to be ubiquitous.
They're everywhere in a cells throughout your body and they,
and they are responsible for lots of,
uh,
of the biochemistry of cell cell interaction and signaling.
Another family has receptor tyrosine kinases.
I'll,
I'll show another picture in a moment that that tells you more about what a,
what a kinase is.
But a kinase is basically an enzyme that can add a phosphorous to another
molecule.
It can,
it can phosphorolate or add a phosphorous to another protein.
And this is a signal.
This passing of phosphorous is a signal that's used very frequently in
intracellular communication.
I'll talk a little bit more about that in a minute.
In this case,
a receptor tyrosine kinase is a receptor molecule that binds a lie again and its
surface outside the cell and initiate this enzyme activity,
this kinase activity and causes phosphorylation of another molecule.
Okay.
And um,
this is,
uh,
there are also other receptors that are linked to other enzymes besides kinases.
And so I've included that as a general family here.
So these are receptors,
for example,
that bind a lie again and then liberate an enzyme which does,
which promotes some sort of reaction inside the cell.
Often it's kinases,
but doesn't have to be
okay.
One of the enzymes that often gets activated is an enzyme which converts ATP,
a small molecule that is insight all of ourselves and ATP is famous.
Or,
um,
it's,
uh,
it's ability to store energy,
but it's also a messenger molecule and when an end,
certain enzyme is activated inside cells,
ATP gets converted into a molecule called cyclic amp.
Cyclic amp is an example of,
of one of these molecules called Second Messengers.
It gets produced in response to a signal.
So there's a binding of a login to a receptor.
The enzyme that does this conversion is,
uh,
is activated and more cyclic amp is released as cyclic amp levels rise inside
the cell.
Something about cell behavior changes right now,
one of the advantages of having second messengers is,
is this is one way that you can integrate between different receptor systems
that are acting inside a cell.
If you have two lie gans stimulating to different receptors and one causes
activation of this enzyme and generation of cyclic amp,
cyclic amp levels will start to rise.
If another receptor operating from a different ligature and does the same thing,
generates an enzyme which causes cyclic amp to increase the rate of cyclic amp
increase is going to go up faster than if only one of these was activated.
Right?
And so the sale is going to experience something different inside because both
receptors were activated instead of just one.
All right.
So sometimes second messengers collect signals from a variety of different uh,
receptor systems,
translate them into one kind of internal change and the cell then just has to
know about that one thing changing.
Does that make sense?
Okay.
Uh,
this is another example of a second messenger,
the UNASA tall lipid pathway.
These are molecules that exist naturally in cell membranes are an activated by
certain enzymes and kinases generated by receptors.
Morris said about this in the book I just included here as an example.
Uh,
but it's sort of beyond the scope of what I wanted to talk about today.
I did want to say a little bit more about kinases because they're so important
in intracellular communication and um,
kinases take advantage of the fact that proteins can often exist in more than
one state and that's what makes them useful molecules inside cells.
That's what's,
that's what makes proteins useful and transmitting or responding to signals.
And often the state of a protein depends on whether its phosphorolated or not.
Now being phosphorolated means that a phosphate group has been added to the
protein and phosphate groups can only be added to certain amino acids along a
protein.
So proteins are only susceptible to uh,
phosphorolation if they have certain kinds of amino acid sequences.
One of the amino acids that can be phosphorylated is tyrasine for example.
And so at protein that has tyrasine and it has tyrasine in a position such that
it's on the outside of the protein and accessible to chemical reaction can be
phosphorylated.
And what a kinase enzyme does is that it recognizes this protein and for
example,
the tyrasine that's on the protein and it performs a chemical reaction on the
protein taking a phosphorous from ATP and moving that phosphorus onto the
protein.
Now,
you know,
already or,
or you could review in,
um,
in chapter four a that I provided to you something about how proteins work and
you know,
that the function of a protein is intimately related to its structure.
Proteins have three dimensional structures in solution and their structure
determines what they do.
And sometimes subtle changes in the structure of a protein can convert it from
an active state into an inactive state,
right?
It's one of the beauties of proteins is working molecules is that their
structure can be changed by subtle means.
And sometimes that subtle change can lead to a big change in the function of the
protein.
Well,
imagine if that,
if that a change in structure could be switched on and off by addition of a
phosphorus and in fact it can in many proteins.
So some proteins can be switched from an off position where they don't do
anything to an on position where they now do something by only a chemical
reaction like this,
uh,
where phosphorus is added.
So,
so kinases can,
in many cases,
serve as a mechanism for switching a protein on or switching a protein off.
If that protein is an enzyme,
then you've switched any switched it from an off position where it's not
catalyzing a reaction to an on position where it is you've,
you've changed the biochemical state of the cell,
you've changed the chemical reactions that can occur within the cell and you've
changed its behavior,
right?
And that's
a very simplified version of why a kinases are important.
Well,
if this kinase happens to turn this protein on,
then you would like to have a mechanism to turn it off as well.
And the other beauty about a beautiful thing about proteins is that if you make
subtle confirmational changes,
often those changes are reversible.
Often those changes are reversible.
Now you all know that we can make irreversible changes in proteins.
You can denature them completely.
It's what happens when you cook an egg,
for example,
right?
You've,
you've taken all the,
all the proteins inside the,
the white of the egg,
for example,
you raise the temperature,
you make,
not small changes in their chemistry,
but big changes in their chemistry.
You denature them,
you can watch them d nature because the egg white turns from clear to white and
it doesn't go back right?
You've irreversibly changed that substance because you've changed the,
um,
the,
the structure of all the proteins inside.
So you can,
that irreversible changes happen all the time too.
Uh,
but here I'm talking about very subtle small changes,
or you're changing the structure of the protein,
but only a little bit such that it can go back.
And one way that you could switch this on and off inside the cell is by taking
off this phosphorous proteins,
enzymes that do this opposite reaction.
The opposite to kinases are called phosphatases.
Okay?
So you could imagine a protein that's existing inside itself at it's some level
of abundance.
There are a hundred of these molecules.
When a receptor gets activated,
a kinase activity gets activated,
the,
the kinase acts on the protein,
the protein gets switched on,
something new starts to happen inside the cell.
Another receptor eventually activates a phosphatase.
That phosphatase now turns the protein off,
that's a switch from outside,
can be used to change the life of a cell.
Okay.
Um,
so that was some,
not too complicated,
but hopefully,
uh,
understandable description of,
of a whole,
uh,
um,
area of biologics biology called signal transduction.
Uh,
if you hear about signal transduction in biology,
people that studied signal transduction arts studying just these things,
we talked about how biochemical messages get,
uh,
get,
um,
uh,
transferred into sales and through cells and want to look at a slightly higher
level of magnification now and think about different kinds of cellular
communication.
And uh,
one kind of cellular communication occurs by similar mechanisms to what we're
talking about.
But here there are receptors on one cell and the,
again,
that they experience is not a dissolved molecule,
but actually a molecule that's attached to another cell.
So sometimes signals are transmitted between sales by sell,
sell,
contact,
and by sell,
sell contact,
I mean that there's a receptor in one cell that that makes some kind of a
chemical interaction with the receptor in another sale.
So depending on which style you are,
you would call one the receptor.
And the other,
the lie again,
right?
And this is a mode of communication that's used very frequently in the immune
system as we'll see as we'll see later.
And it's the way,
for example,
that foreign molecules are antigens get presented to cells of your immune system
in order to start the process of making an immune response.
Okay.
So sometimes it's cells cell interaction.
The rest of these examples referred to receptors as I've been describing them
and lie gins that are soluble and can move around the body.
And it's useful to separate this kinds of signals into three categories.
One is shown at the top of years called Otto Krinn and this is maybe the
strangest because the lie gand that stimulates the receptor is produced by the
cell itself.
So sometimes cells make signals that they receive and what,
and this is commonly used in the immune system as well,
but it's a way of amplifying a signal.
For example,
what if I activated this cell by,
uh,
by encouraging it to produce this particular lie gand and that lie gand was one
for which the sale header receptor that further encouraged it to produce more of
the light gand.
Well then you could imagine a cycle here where activation of the receptor is
leading to production of more lag and is leading to activation of the receptor
and production of a more of a lie.
Again,
that's,
that's an example of a process called positive feedback.
The more of the receptor gets activated,
the more feedback it gets to activate.
And that can be a very strong amplifying response.
Right.
And that happens in the immune system in many cases.
Uh,
an example is a production of certain molecules called cytokines by t cells that
activate themselves.
Yeah.
Another example is called [inaudible].
And here,
uh,
what's different between autocrine and paracrine is that there's some distance
between the cell that produces the signal and the cell that receives the signal,
but it's not too great a distance because the blood system doesn't have to be
involved.
Molecules are produced here and they flow directly over usually by diffusion to
the neighboring molecule.
And Para means near pericrine means signal from nearby.
Endocrin are signals that get carried through the,
um,
through the blood system.
So the cell that's producing the signal produces enough of the molecule.
So that it enters the bloodstream,
it circulates throughout your body.
Eventually it reaches a cell at a great distance,
which has a receptor for that lie gand and the signal gets received.
And an example of that is of course insulin,
which is produced by cells of the pancreas and Axon sales all over the body.
Adrenaline is another one produced by cells and your adrenal gland,
but used by cells all over your body.
Okay,
well the endocrine system is a,
is a body organ system that is uh,
that is specialized in producing these kinds of signals that are used,
that accumulate in the blood,
are used by cells all over the body.
There are two general classes of molecules that are,
that are produced by the endocrine system.
Uh,
all of the molecules are car called hormones.
So a hormone is another name for a lag.
And that operates in this endocrine fashion.
A hormone is just a lie Gann that operates in this endocrine fashion,
but,
uh,
hormones can be proteins.
Endocrine hormones can be proteins,
meaning they're large molecules that are usually fairly water soluble or they
can be steroids and steroids are small molecules,
much smaller than proteins,
smaller molecules that tend to be hydrophobic or lipid soluble example of
protein.
Hormones are insulin,
which we've talked about before and Glucagon and growth hormone,
which we haven't talked about,
but that's very important during,
uh,
during,
periods of lifelike adolescents.
For example,
when rapid growth of your bones is occurring,
um,
well,
insulin is a protein.
It's produced by cells in the pancreas.
It circulates in your blood.
It can't enter cells because it's too big and it's too water soluble,
so it can't go through cell membranes.
And so interacts with receptors called insulin receptors that are on cells that
are sensitive to insulin,
steroid hormones.
On the other hand,
molecules like testosterone and estrogen,
progesterone,
the sex steroids that determine sexual characteristics,
um,
and,
are important for reproductive function are molecules that are all derived from
a similar source.
Many of them are drive,
drive from cholesterol and,
and they're hydrophobic,
which means they can penetrate through cell membranes.
So it doesn't need to bind to a receptor on the surface of the cell in order to
work because the molecule can actually enter the cell directly.
Many steroid hormones act because they bind to cellulars two,
two receptors that are deep within the cell,
often inside the nucleus.
And I'll show how that works in in just a moment.
But estrogen,
for example,
is one of those.
When estrogen is present,
it can enter cells in the vicinity and it can bind to receptors that are deep
inside cells.
So this is a new concept,
right?
Receptors don't have to be these molecules on the cell surface.
There can be receptors that exist in other places within the cell.
For example,
uh,
go a little bit further with this schematic and talking about what insulin does
and um,
and you know about this,
but maybe you haven't thought about it at this level of detail,
but you know that when you,
after you eat,
you eat lunch,
for example,
after class,
you're going to go to lunch,
you're going to eat whatever you eat.
But hopefully it's not a snickers bar.
But let's assume it is a snickers bar and your blood glucose is going to rise
because you've taken a lot of sugar in a,
when it does,
your pancreas receives a signal that your blood glucose has started to go up and
it will secrete insulin.
So there are cells in your pancreas which recognize glucose levels and they
secrete insulin in response.
And when they do that,
this insulin then starts to circulate throughout the blood.
And if you measured,
if somebody measured levels of insulin in your blood after lunch,
if they took it 10 minutes,
30 minutes,
an hour,
you would see that it's going slowly up as it's going up.
It's be,
it's circulating around your body.
And most cells in your body have insulin receptors.
So insulin is starting to bind to insulin receptors on those cells.
And when it does,
it makes biochemical changes inside the cells.
And one of the things it does is include increased glucose uptake into certain
kinds of sales fat cells and muscle cells.
Well,
why does it,
why does it increase uptake of glucose into muscle cells?
Because muscle,
uh,
can use and frequently is using glucose as a source of energy.
And so when there is extra glucose,
you want to put it into the cells that can use it immediately.
Why does it go into fat cells?
Because maybe you ate more Glyn's glucose,
then you need immediately.
And so it goes into cells that can store glucose and that's what fat cells do.
They convert glucose into a form for storage.
Well,
how does glucose uptake get enhanced in those cells?
It gets enhanced because when insulin binds to the insulin receptor,
it activates the receptor.
How does it activate it?
It generates a foe,
a kinase activity,
which leads to phosphorylation of the protein.
So insulin binding leads to phosphorylation,
leads to other biochemical changes.
And eventually what happens is that glucose transport molecules,
which are,
uh,
which are expressed and stored inside the cell get shuttled up to the surface.
So the cells permeability to glucose goes up and more glucose can come in,
right?
This is a highly simplified version,
but sort of closes the loop on what we've been talking about.
Insulin,
the lie again,
binds to its receptor,
creates a change through a kinase activity that's exposed,
which leads to other biochemical changes,
which leads to a change in cell behavior.
In this case,
the cell behavior is that more glucose transporters are brought to the membrane
and more glucose can enter the cell.
Okay,
that's makes sense.
Uh,
sometime after you've eaten,
so you had the snickers bar at lunchtime and you don't have time to get anything
else,
uh,
to eat during the day,
your blood glucose level will go down.
Why does it go down?
Well,
one,
because you're not taking any more glucose in,
but the other,
because when you did eat glucose,
you've got more insulin and the glucose got shuttled into cells where it's
either used or stored.
And so that brings your glucose level down.
Another,
um,
another,
uh,
um,
okay.
Hormone gets produced by the Pancreas in response to low glucose levels.
It's called Glucagon and it has many of the,
of the opposite effects that insulin has.
So not only does insulin go down and stop these behaviors,
but a new hormone called Glucagon gets produced,
which reinforces that change,
right?
And these you're going between these states throughout the day,
And the,
and where your cells experience those states is through these extra cellular lie
gans called insulin and Glucagon,
steroid hormones can operate in a different way because of their structure.
They're small molecules,
they are lipid soluble,
they can go from extracellular to intracellular.
And let's take an example of,
of estrogen.
For example,
a small molecule gets produced by cells.
In one part of the body,
circulates in the blood,
estrogen enters cells,
and sometimes that estrogen is able to penetrate deep within the cell,
even into the nucleus.
The receptor for estrogen is a special molecule called a DNA binding or um,
factor.
Estrogen can combine with this receptor to form a new sort of unit which
interacts with DNA.
Okay.
When this bound receptor interacts with DNA,
it could,
for example,
turn on expression of a target gene.
So one of the things that estrogen does when it,
when cells are exposed to estrogen is that certain genes get turned on that
weren't turned on in the estrogen free state.
It leads to expression of new genes,
production of new proteins,
and a change in the behavior of the cell.
So sometimes receptors when they interact with lye gans create changes in what
proteins are actually being produced by the cell.
And this is one very direct way,
uh,
for that to happen.
These kinds of molecules which uh,
which activate genes,
they are activating the process of transcription there sometimes called
transcription factors.
And this is an example of a transcription factor that is,
uh,
that is itself activated or turned on by the presence of a steroid.
Okay.
That's the end of what I wanted to say today.
Well,
we're going to talk about next time and I encourage you to,
to,
to read ahead because you'll see that there's a lot more detail in chapter six
then what we're talking about here.
I've emphasized the main points,
the ones that I think are important that are clearly important for your
understanding.
We're going to take,
take these general topics and talk about how they work in the nervous system and
the immune system.
Next time.